Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I vouch for you you think
you mad trying to spending half your
life in the cell why did somebody else
live your life
[Music]
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
hello everyone and welcome to the
Fandango first interview with the cast
and filmmakers of Creed Three Michael
Tessa Jonathan welcome I have to start
with you Michael on this one I have to
say it's obviously the continuation of
everything that you've done with Adonis
Creed but also you know back as an actor
more importantly a child actor to now
starring and directing in your
directorial debut what was it why this
story why now this is not the first time
I'm sure somebody's asked you know if or
when uh yeah whoo child acting tonight
yeah it just kind of took me back
um I think uh honestly all roads of my
personal and professional life kind of
led to this moment you know I think
every set that I've been on every
director that I had an opportunity to um
to work with you know other actor that I
had an opportunity to share that space
with kind of led me to this moment to
have a perspective and and to tell a
story about a character that I know very
well and so funny you said from child
actor to now you know I played Adonis
for eight years you know eight years and
I've actually grown up with him so each
movie is kind of like a checkpoint at my
personal life you know and what I have
to kind of offer to the character as
well so this is kind of like you know
the latest update of uh you know mbj and
Adonis all in one so it's it's a it was
a perfect time yeah
and Tessa there's you know these two are
part of everyone has been a part of it
but you've been literally on this
journey since you know test screenings
and you know script read chemistry tests
and such but being on that Journey with
him through this um coming back to it
with Bianca what was different what were
you looking forward and what did you see
with him now behind the director in the
director's chair that you haven't even
seen before even though you guys have
been on this journey together yeah so
much you know is Mike just kind of
alluded to it does feel even though we
were technically adults when we started
making this film it feels like we've
grown up in some ways playing these
characters and certainly every time
we're back
I think we there's a moment we both look
at each other and we're like whoa you
know and we're back here again and also
we're back here as new people because
we've always grown and changed and
shifted and so much has typically
happened for us in between so there is a
thing about I don't know something about
making these films feels like a you
write a postcard to yourself from this
time you know and I think something for
me that felt tremendous on this one is
to get to look at my very dear friends
someone I love very much do something
that is a leap for them and also
something that as Mike said has been
preparing to do for so much of his life
and so getting to to to see that and to
to be able to support him in that it
feels like I get to do what Bianca also
does in these films which is to support
her partner in being the fullest
expression of who he is and it was just
a gift to get to do that to someone who
I love very dearly man it's funny
it's so sweet
it's funny that you say that it's a gift
I will say when I first heard they're
like we're gonna give you a couple more
weeks before you see it it didn't feel
like a gift to me I was mad I was
expecting to see y'all with my mom at
this time but I'm glad that they did
because one of the gifts that that time
gave us is more time to learn a little
bit more about what your character is
going to bring in like interviews and
such and I really loved what you sort of
alluded to in some of the early
interviews is that you know when Mike
called you with the pitch and how you
guys really talked about the character
early on and what he knew you wanted to
bring to this role so just tell me about
those first conversations because what
you brought to it I just I can't wait
for folks to see it's incredible oh it's
deep
those first conversations I mean I feel
like we're still having that
conversation you know I mean the three
of us the chemistry is real our
chemistry began I mean I was in Savannah
Georgia on a FaceTime call
and I was just one I was just blown away
as a a member of the industry and as a
member of the culture to say oh wait who
who wants to talk to me you know what I
mean George was have a conversation with
you I was like
am I in trouble
if I mess up no you know um and uh in
the best way possible
I mean I mean that that's the confidence
that Mike gave uh in that phone call
that I remember you said um it's so odd
for me to say he said you know if we got
a Ferrari you're gonna let the Ferrari
go yeah you know what I mean yeah and I
went I went one I'm in love because you
just call me Ferrari uh so I'm with that
you know and two just uh the humility at
this point I can't go any further
without go ahead and jumping into this
story because I want to let folks know I
got I got a little sample just just a
tiny little sample they didn't let me
eat the whole meal got a couple rounds
so I'm just gonna ask you this Mike
coming into this you had the task of
director of Debut but then you decided
to just do bigger with being one of the
first four Sports movies to shoot in
IMAX and I've seen some of these fight
scenes and after what Ryan and Stephen
did sorry yeah first the first yeah
first it is
congratulations I wonder if the movie
feels like it's an IMAX without it being
an iMac so I don't even know I've seen
it non-imax and it felt Max yeah
see I can't imagine what so talk about
that those cameras that is a daunting
daunting task to really space it out
like that again in your first phone you
know the funny thing is I didn't even it
didn't look like a daunting task to me
it was in my mind the only way I could
have done it uh
being kind of back into a corner of
being the last installment you know or
not lasting but the latest you know what
I'm saying installment of you know this
franchise that all the rocky films all
the cree films before this they've shot
punches a million different ways how do
we do something different you know it
kind of forced me to be a little bit
more creative and to think outside the
box and pull inspiration from different
cinematic kind of areas so having a
fight in IMAX being able to really feel
like you're in the ring with the
fighters is something that is a
challenge that I wanted to see if we can
pull it off and the only way to do that
was with IMAX camera so we were lucky
enough to collaborate with them and they
made it you know um you know accessible
in a way that we got the job done is it
just for the fight scenes just for the
fight yeah yeah so the fight stuff the
you know the walkouts you know we have
you know certain moments where you
actually see the frame open up and you
really get a chance to walk into this
world with our sound design and you know
just everything that we have going
around we were very deliberate and
intentional with the IMAX experience for
both does it change the way that the it
looks even when it's not an IMAX if
you're not watching it in IMAX well
there is there is moments where it goes
back and forth between 190 and 24 and
240 so it's like it goes back and forth
and I think that director
I didn't see it in Onyx but it looks
there's something about the quality of
the fight scenes that look really
different than what we've done before
yeah does that have to do this
also I really want to thank you for the
assist on my job literally doing a
better job
I mean but this is that begs the
question because you're right it is
extraordinary you've been on a ton of
sets that's not something that they
normally do to invest that much time the
other thing I really loved about this
one is seeing YouTube I got to see y'all
settled together as a couple and what I
loved about that particularly is how
settled you were was that this man is
just the ultimate fly in the ointment he
is such a disruptive Force what was it
like bringing that disruption into sort
of you know Adonis and Bianca's world
oh interesting I mean I you know I think
the thing that's always been in in my
estimation really aspirational about
Donna and Bianca's as a couple Adonis
and Bianca biancus
[Laughter]
okay anyways what's cool about these two
I think is you get to see them they feel
they feel to me like a real couple in
the sense that they they have their
issues they have things that they need
to talk about and I think as much as you
you know hope to know your partner and
you get to know them over many years of
being together there are always things
about another person that remain a
mystery to you and I think what you get
to see in them in this installment is
them have to navigate that because he
can't be fully transparent about who he
is if he doesn't know fully who he is
and there's a part of his past that he
hasn't contended with yet and Dame's
reappearance gives him the opportunity
and the challenge of having to do that
and you get to see them figure out how
to do that together and I think that
that's a really sweet thing it's a I
it's so nice to have a successful
relationship captured on screen it
really is and it was quite easy to
disrupt because it was so uh it's so
harmonious you know when Dane walks in I
I saw them the actors and the characters
the space between was was invisible
there was no traction cut go go the way
they moved the way Tesla was supporting
Michael and the way Bianca was
supporting Adonis I could see that you
know and being the new guy on the set
and in the family you know it was so
easy to see okay
that's real love I can really get in
there and try to you know do something
to it so it was uh their relationship
and all the work they've done and their
friendship and all and chemistry on and
off screen was a huge gift
um to the entire franchise but
definitely to me
um and my process to get in there
I had to it's interesting that you say
that this film was the culmination of
everything you've done to get to here
because there's recent work by both of
you that I think we can very much see in
what we see on screen with Damon in the
sense that yes he's the antagonist in
this but the humanity that both your
performance and what was written about
him has is exceptional like it really is
one of those things it's another one of
those like I don't agree with them but I
understand situations because we also as
we all come across but talk about how
you and Mike um worked on humanizing
that humanizing him as the antagonist
through this because I know that was a
huge part of what you wanted to do with
character Damien is a collaboration his
name changed when we got together uh his
last name is my maternal grandfather's
last name you know Mike allowed that to
come in so what we ended up doing was
implicating ourselves in the creation of
um this character you know implicating
our ancestors implicating black men
black masculinity you know and so we we
got to really evaluate and examine that
and I think our goal was to
bring a real human being to the screen
in order to have a real relationship
between the two
um yeah it was two sides of the
conversation you know we we needed both
sides of those conversations you know we
want to put a mirror up to our audience
and to each other and challenge the way
we think of the way we look at each
other that sense of identity that
Brotherhood and bond and you know the
you know it always take the hard way I
mean that was the other series because I
mean I mean
Michael has done incredible work in his
in his career and incredible work in the
film there's a certain level of
um he has a high standard you know I
have a high standard you know and so we
go okay we're making this guy we're
we're actually collaborating and
competing to figure out how to make how
to contribute the most to making this
you know I mean and the beauty of it is
we've got the lead of our film and the
director so the director's backing me up
right after I'm trying to take his head
off right but the director I'm like yeah
bro let's go
priority yeah the priorities got to run
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so great that
you talk about freedom because I would
imagine with your relationship that
freedom is built with trust but it's so
refreshing to hear that everybody who
came onto this journey with you got to
experience that level of freedom but I
know on this one you got more freedom
again you've lived in this character I
mean almost as much as you know I'm not
going to mention her but you know who
I'm talking about uh you know what I
mean like you've gotten to live in this
character
I mean I made Mission Billy from Cold
Case and we'll really go back oh my gosh
but you got
you really got to um we read that you
got to have more you know takes with
Bianca and sort of showing especially in
motherhood
it's always been a real pleasure of
playing this character from the
beginning I mean the the Bianca that we
see in Creed one was really Ryan would
we do rehearsals and Ryan would have
sometimes like just record us ad-libbing
and then it would end up in the in the
screenplay we've always worked really
actively
um with from the script process to
development there's I mean there's so
many things stuff that Bianca literally
wears that I went and shopped I mean I
remember the first idea of her was a
picture that Ryan coogler had taken of a
girl on the you know on the train
um in Philadelphia and we were like how
do we find this girl and then it was a
process of doing that and so to get to
continue to do that I think what felt
very nice in this process especially is
early on Mike being like hey like sit
with the writers and let's figure this
out and he's always you know there's a
tremendous amount of trust that he put
with me to be able to work through the
dialogue and figure out this woman and
who she is at this juncture in her
trajectory which is really exciting work
to get to do and and then also just the
kind of work that you get to do just on
you know on set I think there's a real
shorthand between us that yes is earned
by years but I there's a rare thing that
happens occasionally when you have that
sort of immediacy with a person which I
think we always have had which has just
been a a great thing for us in this in
this journey thank you all so much and I
want to remind everyone that tickets for
Creed 3 are on sale now